what about a parade for dudes that bust
quick
like that that's the premiere parade
yeah yeah the premature parade
and like i identify that's my
orientation
and you're like wow that is you're gonna
shame my identity like that
ryan long welcome to the show we're here
yeah yeah i thought we were recording i
was i was trashing everybody in the
industry i was like
i was getting into it you're in full
flow already yeah you're right
trending headline right now big headline
andrew cuomo's daughter has come out as
demisexual did you see this
yeah she's hot too did you see her yeah
it's weird
yeah yeah um uh demisexual
is like the that's the epitome of like i
want in the club
and you go i don't know if i'm you know
are you gay no and you go
demisex was the funniest you changed
nothing you changed nothing at all
you changed nothing yo you are i'm i'm
attracted to like people's personalities
so for the people that don't know it's
like uh the only feel sexually attracted
to someone when there's an emotional
bond
like how that qualifies as an
orientation
i feel so you know i'm just i'm sad that
she had to go through that
and i'm you know coming out of the
closet that's hard for people you know
what i mean when you come out and you go
listen i am attracted to people who i
like their personalities
everyone's like oh my god like your life
is so hard
they should make a separate parade for
you they need a they need a demi priv
dave demi pride parade do you know
what's making me laugh the idea of
do you know there is an article saying
that they have they're going to have
kink in the
whether they should have kink for kate
like in the pride parade you know like
the guys with paul
i want to go i i want to do a street
thing we're asking people
like wearing the leather and stuff
saying that uh we're trying to campaign
to get kink at the thanksgiving day
parade
got the turkeys all dressed up in
leather
yeah yeah we think that that's only
reasonable but the demi parade they need
their own parade that's
um it's a tough affliction well it says
everything now right that
like demisexual is is like the biggest
counter culture that you could have
like that you actually have to take a
little bit of time before you get
involved in some sort of
sexual explicitness
yeah yeah i mean i don't know if they
take time they just have to like the
personality i think you could still be a
hoe and baby
oh okay that's all right yeah yeah
that's interesting so it doesn't
actually need to take time to get the
emotional bond you just need to like the
personality
what about uh a parade for dudes that
bust quick
like that that's the premise
yeah yeah the premature parade and like
i identify that's my orientation
wow that is you're going to shame my
identity like that
well what about the alternative what's
like the opposite of a demisexual like
the guy that will just sleep with
anything
doesn't care at all if the person that
wants to wait and needs the emotional
connection doesn't sleep with the person
that wants to [ __ ] them within three
seconds
is that discrimination yeah well no and
what i'll tell you is probably the best
way of describing all this stuff
is it's all like girl stuff you know and
even like the dudes that are on board
with it it's girl stuff so it's like
what she did was essentially they've
taken a really long route
to like have a a term for just like what
every girl a little bit is
you know what i mean so it's like the
the this demisexual is the end
of the line where now every single girl
can have like an interesting term
yeah you're gonna have membership into
the club but it's the lowest barrier to
entry
of anyone and then we can all we can all
just be like listen yeah girls you do
all this like stuff and you can give
yourself all your titles and like we can
not care anymore
i love it man and dudes can go back and
just [ __ ] plow and play
the premature parade at the premature
parade yeah
if you're a girl do you reckon you do
only fans because i spend
far more time than you'd expect thinking
about whether or not i'd do only funds
if i was a girl
really well you can as a guy right but
there's like a way
only there's the guy waiting yeah there
is there's a gender wage gap
terrifying yeah do you know what else
there is that i've been talking with us
on stage but there's a
there's a red hair wage gap i don't know
if you know that
where people would rather make less
money they make less money
and some people think it's because of
the jobs they take like there's less
money in being a carnival operator or a
backyard wrestler or uh biting the heads
off chickens
but um i thought
i thought that i thought you meant that
they made specifically less on only fans
like people were like i don't want to
see that ginger pubic hair
but i identify as part of the community
i have a few reds in my beard yeah but
you probably
too me too yeah exactly we're a very
very ostracized people
uh i don't know if i would to be honest
i mean
it's hard to i i think i always have
this conversa it's always funny to like
that conversation like if i was a girl
and people always say this with races
right they're like if you were a black
guy like would you think like this and
i'm like well am i still me or am i
different guy
like because if i'm still me like i have
a pretty
contrarian like personality like my
guess would be that i would find myself
like in whatever counter culture
you know surrounded me then but if like
if you're like well you're
uh you have a different brain well then
you're like well yeah then yeah i'd be
different in that scenario if i'm a
different guy
but with the girl if i if i'm me
i think that i'd be a you know probably
doing some version of
comedy or you know something like that
as a girl but if i'm like some
yeah so it's hard to say because if i'm
me still probably not but
what's the is there a difference in male
comics and female comics
in terms of what they get i mean why
don't you get into your opinions on that
no i mean is there a difference in terms
of how much they get paid
yeah yeah there's guy comedy and then we
go okay guys uh i hope you had fun at
that
person now we're gonna do the uh there's
some girl comedy boys in the show
i didn't know i didn't know that it was
that bad i mean when you think about the
netflix specials and stuff
not a massive amount of women on there
i think that um i think that uh
there is like a difference in if your
masculine voice feminine like how you do
well but it's the same thing in real
life you know what i mean
if uh i mean there's you're commanding a
room full of people you know what i mean
so it kind of is just like a masculine
art form to begin with
and people are comfortable hearing uh a
woman
talk about different things than a man
and there's there's
there's like here's a perfect example
like if you were
at like a bar or something like that and
some girl comes up to you and kind of
like
makes fun of you you might not feel
something about that right but if a guy
came up to you and he kind of like tried
to
come out of nowhere and take a dig at
your personality or something in front
of your chick you're like
yo what the like so there's just
different you know the girl a girl can
come steal your hat at a bar and it's
not gonna be a fight whereas a guy can
right
but then there's vice versa with that
right so on stage it's the same thing
like everyone
is willing to like take take different
uh you know you're allowed to kind of do
different things based on like the
culture of
people there on dates right so if you're
a girl you want to make sure that girl
doesn't think you're like trying to
steal her dude and there's
if you're a guy the same thing right so
there's like just these all these like
dynamics that are no different than real
life
demisexual that's the solution everybody
stay demisexual
and then you're all safe from it it
literally
solves all problems and it solves the
problems of
if every girl is in like the victim
class then you know you
kind of you know don't really have to
hear it about it anymore
it's just everyone that's true i had
this quote uh
carl benjamin guy from over here said in
the same way that constant access to
porn is deforming men's expectations
of women only fans is deforming women's
expectations of men
that was something that i'd never really
thought about the fact that
the way that the girls that perhaps do
only fans or maybe have a friend that
does only fans or
even a friend that i don't know is on
the outside you know they just do foot
stuff
maybe or i don't know something else
yeah what that means for sort of the
relationship between
a girl and a guy now like what do they
expect from each other i think that was
quite interesting
there's there's kind of i always like
think that
the one of the biggest problems with um
everything right now and like the
biggest like disconnect in the
conversation
is that people want to like normalize
things that are sort of like cowboy
lifestyles
and like for me like i've sort of lived
a cowboy lifestyle like i was you know
i've been like a
comic and been on the you know lived on
tour to 2200
you know days a year and never had a
normal job and then scraped by doing
this and then was kind of
like i've just lived this like super
alternative lifestyle my entire life
right
and even with when it comes to like
relationships and a lot of times and
stuff like that
but it's like a hard thing to do and it
takes like a specific type of person and
it also takes
you know kind of a lot of uh trying to
i don't know if like mental resilience
but you need to like focus on
you know not being a mess because
otherwise you just end up like a
depressed alcoholic or some [ __ ] right
so i think that if you're a certain type
of person
none of this matters but the truth is
like yeah if you're like a
certain type of you know let's say a
weaker person you go yeah you
probably can't handle that lifestyle but
some people can so that's
it all depends on like who you are you
know what i mean i don't think it's as
simple as
it is or isn't good it's like yo are you
the type of person that can handle this
[ __ ]
and then if when they're not they do it
and then they go society needs to like
change to make
this easier and you go nah you weren't
suited for that thing
that's what i think like kind of a lot
of this stuff uh
revolves around but the same way if
you're a dude that's like out there
smashing like if you're
some 20 year old it's just like running
through chicks or like let's say a
hockey like a like a
you know professional football player or
something you know what i mean or
whatever in a famous rapper or something
right those guys it's the same sort of
thing like you when you when women are
that disposable like it does make you uh
think of girls as like look at it like
they're nothing you know what i mean
and they're all schemey like they're all
up to something you don't trust them and
it's
a because the type of girls you're
around and how they are around you
and b like you just see like the worst
side of them i think
i can't remember who the rapper was
probably but a rapper came to newcastle
and had sent one of his assistants out
into the crowd
and uh wanted to sleep with a redhead
that night
so his assistant yeah and a couple of
her friends had gone out into the crowd
on like redhead watch
and they'd gone and spoken to four or
five different redheads that were in the
crowd that they thought
like yeah like the rod stewart style
yeah it could be suitable candidates
like tonight i fancy
someone lithuanian let's find someone
lithuanian in the crowd
yeah it turns you into this psychopath
[ __ ] mental
i couldn't believe that apparently this
girl had turned up and in the tour bus
there was her
and four of the redheads yeah and then
the
the rapper is like hmm after much
deliberation
i decided to go with fat white chick
again
for the ninth night in a row sire
but the plebs they are not up to
standard tonight
yeah exactly so yeah i guess like
being that guy probably you know makes
you think that they're
especially after some chick that's
online still on your feet and
you have about 9 000 dudes like simping
like
but if i give you an extra 20 bucks can
you say yeah it's like you're like yo
dudes are losers
but difficult to hold on to that man but
i think um
it's interesting about having
the drugs and the sex but none of the
rock and roll
as a part of that like you can live the
lifestyle
you can live the lifestyle of someone
that's this sort of traveling
itinerant that's good yeah no [ __ ]
girls always good like there's no dude
that's living the lifestyle of a
billionaire without being a billionaire
guess what there are a million girls
that are out there living like they're a
billionaire right now so
this ain't a new thing that like girls
can [ __ ]
you know live like that even without
doing the thing that's you know what a
groupie was whatever
but this you know me yeah they don't
even have to be like odd now
dude there's jigs they're like sixes and
they're like yo top one percent only
fans are like
if you're just so funny dude by some
if you've got in your bio london miami
dubai
and no verifiable source of income
that's what's happening those guys are
funny yeah i agree those guys are so
funny with all that like you live in
every
city i know i know some specific dudes
like that they are like live in every
city and you're like you're on a couch
have you got any money in crypto yeah i
got like i don't know like
30 grand or something all right have you
learned anything over
the last year because it's been i just
have a theory of bitcoin dude my body
just [ __ ]
made a fortune like he went long bitcoin
short dodge coin and like
short like let mad like leverage shorted
dogecoin
like but but he he uh uh what do you
call it
um hedged it by by having long bitcoin
in his mind but
that trade he like destroyed on but
no i kind of i kind of just have
probably like 70
ethereum 30 bitcoin i just have it
i think my body said this and i maybe
agree a little bit i'm sure like
if you're like you know you're into
crypto more that
it might sound stupid but it is to me a
little like
of a like fashion it's almost like a
little fashionable
i think i agree with that but you know i
don't have like some crazy percentage of
portfolio in there or something why
is that are you like a big big no not at
all not at all no
i i've got like a few grand in that was
like fomo coin
i just thought right i need to put
something i need to put something in
because everybody else is talking about
it
managed to snipe not quite at the top
but not far off the top on a bye
and i'm like right okay well this was
this was a fun way to lose five grand
i just did a sketch um uh
elon musk groupie support group about
like all the twos they were just like
you know what i mean just hanging out
his word and he don't even move the
markets anymore
so that's uh i did that with so my that
guy danny has to just mention
he runs he we used to i used to run
uh the video department and i was a part
owner of this website called the hard
times and they have a website called the
hard money which is like a financial
satire site
it's pretty funny so we're doing it as
like a collaboration with those guys
that's pretty cool did you see uh
yeah it's interesting i'm not gonna i'm
just leaving i like
i i don't i haven't sold it i didn't i
bought it on coin i like a coin base
like those fees are so ridiculous too
like but i was just because of my
all my banking so screwed up just
because like i immigrated here not long
that long ago and there's just so it's
like i literally was just like screw it
i'll take a hit
and i just like when it was down a lot i
bought you know i just kind of bought in
and
i'll probably leave it for 10 years or
something i'm not going to think about
it it's
weird to me because so many of the
people that are passionate about bitcoin
or blockchain or whatever
just seem to be passionate about making
money but it's all guarded underneath
like yeah man but decentralized it means
that the people in the third world can
make their payments from wherever they
want it's like you don't care
you don't care about people in ghana
being able to send money back to their
grandmother
you care about the fact that it doubles
every couple of months
yeah well you have to kind of like
because legitimately
you got to be like a sales person right
it's because the whole thing's based on
perception so if you have your army out
there convincing people like
legitimately you say it doubles every
two months well if every single one of
those guys is able to convince one
person at a bar
to invest like they did it'll keep
doubling
why not in that case why not say why
don't just like go completely open and
say
i like bitcoin in the blockchain because
it doubles every two months and stop
talking
about people in ghana sending money to
their mother
because i think you need the there's
i mean think of it with a stock if
someone was telling you who cares what
the company is it doubles every month
like that's not going to convince people
like you need to get them as part of the
gospel
like you need to they need to believe
that this is this is not just
like that there's value here that
they're investing in the future like
they
no one wants to invest in you know what
is by that description a ponzi scheme
right i mean if you can change something
from a ponzi scheme to not a ponzi
scheme
simply by changing the advertising i'm
not sure that that's
the most stable foundation for it to be
built on yeah
i mean i i i'm of the
probably the best way to describe it is
like listen
this if bitcoin and this blockchain
technology is kind of the future
there is only a limited part of it it'd
be the equivalent of if it's like there
was
back in the day when the internet came
out and everyone you could invest in
you own one percent of the internet
right now and there is only a certain
amount and it became the biggest thing
and it does have a value
so that would probably be the best
description where you go okay but
there's also 45 000 other places saying
we're going to be the main internet
and then there's also all the
regulations and then there's also
the government's going to be like yeah i
don't think you guys are out of your
mind if you think you're going to own
the [ __ ] internet
if we're not you know and what so
there's all this
you know it's like a lot going on right
man i watched this documentary
this like miniature documentary on
youtube about john mcafee
last night have you looked at this you
looked at all of this [ __ ] it's crazy
i used to pay attention to him he was
the man so the john mcafee stuff's
wild yeah and he legitimately said
you know and this isn't getting any
coverage because of whatever
you know maybe my little you know
circles of getting coverage but
to the real world the guy well yeah you
can i don't know if you're going to like
intro or whatever you go away man you
tell you tell the story i'll jump in
yeah so mcafee he
you know he invented mcafee antivirus
became a big guy then he became like i'm
gonna be the exposing government secrets
guy
he was paying money on the dark web to
get all this stuff went to jail in
mexico
and there's lots more to that but he was
like heavy on the podcast scene like he
was out there
saying uh you know conspiracy stuff for
however you want to put it
and then he made all these videos in
jail being like
i'm would never kill myself like he has
a tattoo
he goes this is a tattoo that says i
would never kill myself
i love my wife i love my life and i'm
still
in perfect mental state but i have a
feeling they're trying to
and he just kept making these videos
like they're trying to kill him i will
not kill myself
and then the next day they're like
suicide john mcafee found dead in
barcelona or something
yeah [ __ ] man did you see so i watched
this
jake tran who's the youtuber he makes
sick
sort of short documentaries if anyone
wants to find out more about this
mcafee situation i'll put the i'll find
the link and put it in the show notes
um he made the antivirus software
in a day and a half
really took him a day and a half to code
it and within
a month four million companies were
using it and then within two years
half of the fortune 500 companies had it
on there on their computers and it took
him a day and a half and then he got
some some guy that he lived next door to
supposedly poisoned his dogs and then
the next day that guy was found dead
and john mcafee was like don't know what
you're talking about
don't know what you're talking about
nothing to do with me
i didn't know that part of the story
wildman it was in some
some crit not venezuela but some equally
mental country
and uh yeah and then he had schwecked
didn't he hash like
dollar sign whacked on his uh tattooed
on his arm and that was
also his crypto that you could buy but
it was
i'll never be killed and then the final
thing was he said um
he tweeted out that 16
terabytes of government secret data is
going to be released and i can't stop it
if anything ever happens to me but that
hasn't come out yet that sucks
yeah that's a bummer it did seem like
that yeah he
he was really hard on if i die
everyone's going down with me
and then he died and no one was still
waiting for the package
i know wait is it because he's got a
lawyer that's tweeted something else as
well
saying um i'll i've i can't stop it once
the wheels are in motion there's no way
for me to stop it sounded like he's
setting off a
nuclear reaction or something but yeah i
mean yeah
that's what that's what everyone's
waiting for if he's got to be if he's
got to go and he was like 75 i mean he'd
had like
he'd lived a pretty crazy life given the
fact he was 75 but
and he was like this you know kind of
ladies man type
you know he was trying to be like a hugh
hefnery sort of situation for a while
like he was really letting
letting the money fly and uh trying to
live this dan blizzari any sort of
lifestyle
he was really into scat which according
to some of his ex-girlfriends
was an interesting insight
dude i always see like the damn blizzard
even went back if he was doing where
it's like i get the idea of at the end
of the night you know whatever
you're like i'm gonna have sex or do hot
chicks the damn blizzarian he goes on
these trips with like seven girls
it's like have you ever like hung out
with your like like a chick you're
dating and like two or three of her
friends
it's like what that's your life you just
hang out with these like seven
squawking freaking insta0s like that
that's your
imagine you go on a trip to a island
with just you and seven
annoying girls like this guy must be
like the biggest loser
like who the only person i could think
that would want to do that is like a gay
dude
like one of your gay friends be like oh
i'm hanging out with the seven chicks
like it's the thing that the
ambassadorian does he's like cool right
now i'm like i'd rather
shoot myself than be in a private jet
with like
seven models from instagram that don't
really know each other like what is this
well it's cool for the moment that that
photos taken like if you were able to
maybe he's completely trolled everyone
and he just gets the girls in for that
and then they have to [ __ ] off and stay
in a different apartment
and he's just he just sits up late at
night like playing card and
reading philosophy or something yeah it
is the business model like i guess there
is a part of it where it's like
i get that where you're like no but i
have to do this because this is my
business as i go
take these photos heavy price to pay
more it's a heavy price to pay but also
why who thinks this is cool
i'm just like like how does any guy fool
like i can't i don't know a single guy
that would they would see like
seven you're like my chick and seven hot
girls are going on a trip and they say
that you could have
sex if you come when you go can i just
show up that now you like do i really
this is what's insane this is where the
internet
gets things so much quicker than even
anyone else
because i was seeing dan bilzerian is
the ultimate man child
i was seeing videos with those sorts of
titles
18. oh the internet turned on two years
ago
and this was before yeah yeah exactly
but you start to see that well before
even like
the other internet you think there's so
many layers to the level of
investigation that people are prepared
to do you know you mean
yeah they're so ahead of the curve with
that they're out of the curve with like
we don't like that anymore too with
things yeah as soon as
like there is a very if you're on that
pulse of the internet
when people are talking about that stuff
and you go in six months you'll hate him
you know what i mean like you can kind
of already see the like elon musk was a
perfect example of that
like what did you mean it was you well i
saw the
the he you know he was like on this cool
[ __ ] poster dude and everyone was kind
of like elon musk is sick and
doing the rogue appearances and all that
stuff and i could see the bumbling
underneath the people being like
this guy's a loser like you know what i
mean and like not even
the way that the media hated him where
the media you know lies about him and
doesn't like guys like him
i could see that people was like
regardless of that stuff it's like this
guy isn't
annoying like i could just see the the
fumblings of that the same way
they turned on white claw like it was
a jewel and then yeah like all that
stuff like you could see that it was
turning like quick like you know what i
mean you can see how quickly it
it turns they're trying to launch in the
uk at the moment white claw
oh it doesn't have it there no well it
it does now but only just
oh well i'm in canada and they didn't
have it in canada when i came here
and when i came here i was like this is
the best and that was for like three
days i was telling everyone i was like
this white cloud thinks game changer
i was here for about a week before it
turned into like yo you drink white
glass you're gay dude
[Laughter]
they were giving it the like the you
know the treatment like you're drinking
a cooler you know what i mean
like that they switched hard i think the
beer companies like
loki like if you work for like bud they
launch like the underground like
i don't know maybe they own white club
but maybe that's what it is but
your companies have their underground
dude i had this woman
i had the woman who uh who did the fire
festival documentary
on okay and um she did this big
investigation into a bunch of other
brands that basically used the same
model
that sort of really weaponized meme
about their enemies
exactly yeah so social media influence
and all this sort of stuff
and um white claw and jewel
and wework were three of the biggest
ones that came up
right so what what did jewel do like
they they
they tried to pretend like to be doing
vape tricks was like yeah
like ripping a jewel and this sort of
stuff but you saw it it was oh
they just seeded [ __ ] tons of products
to
micro influences with between like three
and 10k
just seeded everybody with it and then
all of the people that were below that
thought that's the [ __ ] that's what
everyone's using
but yeah you're right like when when
people see through it like if you if the
come up is this hard then the come down
tends to be pretty
sharp as well it does yeah
i mean jewel i got everyone oh doc when
i'm i i never like smoked properly and
when i came here i had i had a good like
four or five months where i was i was
like on the jewel pretty much you would
have jewels at a bar
yeah and i would just be like yo this
kind of rules and then
at one point and then i started buying
disposables then i got one and then
and then i'd be like jeweling while i'm
editing during the day and then a couple
weeks ago i go all right this is done
we're we're going cold turkey we will
just quit it
like i'm not starting smoking at 35.
it's
i made it so long yeah dude i go
it's ridiculous like what i just started
smoking like because it's you know i
thought it was just because some
teenagers told you that it was cool
yeah at some point i'm like okay well
now i it started
as like i guess ironic you know like
this is there's nothing ironic here i
just do
them
[Laughter]
just a sad i'm just a sad 35 year old
smoking while he edits a video yeah
yeah i'm sitting there in my underwear
editing videos and [ __ ] jeweling and
i go this isn't good
[Music]
just i just stopped like i've done you
there's an affiliate on tick tock who's
retired off the back of your commission
but is laughing his way to the bank as
well yeah yeah
yeah no it is but yeah it is one of
those things too where it's
you know their jewel was like hey we're
hip and it's like
yeah i mean you legitimately just got a
generation of kids addicted to smoking
you guys are [ __ ] evil it's fairly
powerful yeah if that's one thing to do
did you see this this olly london story
the guy from the uk
got surgery to look like a korean person
do you see this
yeah that guy he's from uk rules
yeah even rachel dolezal uh
rachel dolezal was like giving him props
it feels like one of your sketches it
feels exactly like one of your sketches
i haven't been able to really do a trans
sketch that i felt like was good enough
to make
without it seeming like hacky i actually
filmed one and then didn't even release
it because i didn't feel like it was
good enough and i
rarely do that because the trans stuff
is the one that
like exactly like doing something like
trans-racial it just i don't know it
feels like hack to me
like boomery or something so i couldn't
i could i couldn't
uh i've never been able to think of
something with trans stuff that i didn't
think
you know i get a million people being
like do like a trans guy winning like
the
trans woman winning olympics like oh i'm
not doing that
but it was making me laugh i just went
to a hot dog eating competition
uh two days ago so the america you know
eating the competitive eating in america
i've seen i was
i'm not going to do this but it was like
making me laugh the idea of if a trans
oh because because the the winner for
the guys when
you eat 78 the winner for the girls was
like 23. like it's not even
like the difference oh okay so an eating
competition would be a real difference
between the two
yeah yeah probably more than anything
yeah yeah because boys are socialized to
eat more than girls
yeah yeah yeah that's the reason dude
there's these one guy joey chestnut
by the way i've heard of him i've seen
him on the internet it it's
it's incredible and uh the announcers
take it seriously my favorite part is
has he got walkout music oh yeah
they have walking music they they
announce it like kind of a mix between
wrestling and basketball
and the one guy pukes in the announcer
goes a reversal
oh no i call it a reversal
so he no he's like a celebrity when he
comes out joey chess not like
the other guys you know some of the guys
don't even want to compete because he's
so much better than everyone else it's
like bad for their eating brand to just
go get spanked by joey chestnut right
but the funniest part to me was the girl
guy thing
so the guys it's so serious and there's
real like money in it the endorsements
they have two referees each so there's
like 10 people on the stage and each guy
has two referees that stand under them
and when they finish a hot dog the
referees have a sign they have to both
sign off
and if the both referees agree that that
was a full dog they put it on the board
you know what i mean like they give the
hand they have all these symbols
on the girls they have one referee for
20. it's like honor system they're like
i don't know how much do you think you
just
that's how i like literally care about
the girls they have 20 referees each
guy's two referees the girl one they're
just like
after you finish like i don't know write
on a piece of paper how many you think
you probably ate
oh my god yeah yeah but no i was it was
super fun
what was that coney island
and this is uh you know when uh like you
know metropolitans people talk about how
they're so
like liberal or whatever but then you go
10 minutes out it's a whole different
world right
this is they go i go there they first of
all
uh oh do you still see me yeah so first
of all
they bring out um the mayor de blasio
he's like the mayor he's the mayor here
for the east coast he's kind of like
yeah but he's supposed to um but he's
like the super liberal mayor and they
don't like him right now
well in in new york they do but anywhere
else they don't right
he's got the hot dog eating competition
the hat on and he's trying to be like
cute he's like you know i relish
in the opportunity to be here and i was
like go [ __ ] yourself
you know the girl who won the
competition her name is melissa i think
it was
and then he goes he goes on and then
she's giving he's giving her the award
and people are yelling
you deserve better melissa and then
they bring out that so this he's just
like i don't
even want to really be here like he's
just trying to you know
so then then after he finishes they
bring out the head
prosecutor like the d.a and what's he
gonna do
what's he there for he comes out he
comes out and he's like he's like in the
mafia type you know attitude right he's
there with his two boys his sons and
he's like
i'm just here i'm telling you that i'm
about to keep these streets safe and i
was like hell yeah brother
so everyone's cheering for this guy
because like
like imagine in new york like they're
trying to defund the police we're
freaking half hour over they're cheering
for like the head prosecutor right
so it's it's just like so funny how much
of a different world the hot dog eating
competition brings out the trash
jesus christ yeah i was having i was
like laughing so much that
you know anything they mentioned about
colvin wearing a mask everyone's like
[ __ ] you
like
it was funny man it's so funny that you
say about how
it was too boomery basically to do a
trans
scat or to to try and come up with one
it feels a bit hacky or whatever stand
up about
it i've done stand up about it but yeah
i haven't i haven't thought of a sketch
that doesn't
doesn't that show like just how sharp
the bleeding edge or the subtle edge of
culture is at the moment
that like one of the main things that's
seen as part of the culture war
is in a guy that focuses on
political and cultural and sociological
different phenomenon it's it's like too
obvious even though it's the main story
but the fact that is one of the main
stories makes it too obvious
yeah dude you gotta there's like so much
to it and that's what
all at the end of the day you have to
just trust your instincts and you can't
always explain it
like a lot of times on stage i used to
you know one of those things where
you want people on stage being like oh
yeah like i've been trying to say that
not like you know where you kind of say
it you realize everyone was
already agreeing with you like there's
there's some version of that and then on
top of that
you need to be able to understand what
the interpretation is that's why on
stage i like it more because people can
see me
and i control how they see it and i can
react if i feel like
they're agreeing too much in a certain
way i'll kind of pull the other way and
i can kind of
i can kind of maneuver people's brains
to where i like wanted them to be i
think
but on the internet you can't really
control how people interpret it so
if i felt like i was gonna you know do
a joke about that stuff i'd have to
really make sure that it's not gonna be
like weaponized where it's like
everyone's like
yeah a few freaking trans like you know
what i mean because that's
especially if that wasn't my position so
i think there's also the inability
the the like the level which you think
it's going to be like misinterpret or
misappropriate or weaponized for like
some cause that you didn't want to
so and again i told you i was saying off
camera before but that's why i like
don't like doing a lot of those
political abundance stuff because they
just
they take away your message and
bastardize it because they
uh they can't be trusted
well that was something i was thinking
about like how do you avoid audience
capture in that way because you can get
wrapped up in being the new darling of
the left or the right or
whoever resonates with the point that
you're making or hates the people that
you're mocking right
do you ever feel the temptation to kind
of lean in to give people what they want
to hear and then kind of how do you how
do you avoid that capturing
the dark arts right like i think of that
as
um the the dark arts of this whole thing
it's kind of
like you could there there's that and
making money there's that in business
like you know you're like ah we could
probably grow quicker of this i could
probably get more girls if i did this
like there's always
you know if i could get more girls if i
just lied you know what i mean
like there's there's like why not just
straight up lie and say you got a
million
you know whatever but it might not be
good long-term strategy
so um yeah you you gotta be
i mean for starters i think the most
important thing it helps
uh uh doing it for so long that i
that i my opinions aren't gonna change
like i've seen a lot of people that when
it happens what you said
they could become a darling of this
something and then you know you see them
a year later and they just have all the
opinions of that thing lo and behold
you know like i'm not gonna change what
i think about nothing like i've been
uh in this game
you know talking about stuff form and
opinions for a long time right so i
think what i
have i think my perspective is
infallible to
you know uh people telling me what they
think i should think or whatever like
but then on top of that i think the only
thing you can really do to avoid like
pandering
is you have to be willing to like take
the hits
especially and it gets tough like you
know right now it's a little
it's a little then you know the news is
a little calmer right
and it's you know everyone kind of
builds a brand an election cycle
especially if you talk about culture
things are a little bigger on the
internet there's more to be said the
pandemic lots was happening
and then when that starts dropping a bit
you see people just go for like hard
panders you know
and i think that's with stand up
everyone knows there's people that you
know
that are good like kill but everyone's
like yeah but that sucks right
so you need to you get better at like
who's the real criticism and then you
need to
sift out you go people go this sucks
like you go
is this people that are just like
writing me off because they disagree
or is this people that that are have
legitimate criticisms
and you need to be able to like sift is
this people that like me that
you know i've gone the other way a lot
of people that someone like me
uh i don't even need to like mention
names but there's a lot of big comics
that would kind of come out
of what me people like me the new like
dissonant comedy
voices if you want to put it in some way
like that they'll go
oh um these guys you know are
bad or their fans are bad or whatever
right and i'll go nah dude like
i know you want to be you love that's
what you'd love if i was just this right
guy like
you [ __ ] that would be perfect for
you but that's not the case you know who
loves me people that used to like you
like really a lot of these people it's
like we'll go to this they'll be on my
shows and be like yeah i used to like
that guy he's kind of weird now you know
what i mean
he's kind of all like the only thing you
he's just like a political pundit now
i like you because you know you kind of
make fun of everything
and then but so they can those people
are looking at this and lying to
themselves about what's the reality
they go oh they're just well i guess all
my old fans just turned into nazis like
you know
so i think you need to try to that's you
know do stand up
a lot don't lie to yourself about what
you think is funny where you go
you're putting stuff out that you know
is just like red meat for pandering
and uh yeah it's a it's a tough one
though because
that's what you see a lot of these
companies that their goal is just to
kind like internet companies especially
just to make as much money as possible
get as much clicks as possible
and they end up bastardizing like you
know
what's good to be honest you know what's
that word
where the audience is just the only
reason that they're applauding is
because they're agreeing there's like a
word for it in the comedy circle people
say clapter is that what you mean
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it um
but you see that a lot right and i've
heard other comics talk about it as well
that you don't necessarily need to be
funny
to actually get a relatively good set
out now you just need to say things that
reinforce the
beliefs or the prejudices that the
people that sat in your audience
for that you and this is you know see
this is kind of that thing where i go
you know [ __ ] fox news in those places
like that
they put that narrative out there it's
this is
like it's not really that true it's like
dude there was maybe a moment
where in the right thing in front of
your fans if you're like some super
trump's the worst guy
and you go to your fans yes the same way
that if you're
some super right wing guy and you go to
your fans and you're like
yo biden's old effort i'll be like yeah
dude yeah like isn't it this guy
freaking sucks
you go and then they go oh yeah like you
know what i mean
and then so it depends on it depends
really on
like what your side is but if in the
real world in comedy clubs if you went
out right now
you're like and that's the reason that
trump friggin
uh you know sucks in this and that a lot
of people in the audience kind of roll
their eyes right now
like people audiences aren't as stupid
as people want to say they are you've
been following this story about the
mumford and sons things obviously you
were in a you're in a band i guess this
might have a special place in your heart
yeah yeah that this one's like funny
because it is like
the truth is if you're in a band
and you're going to get out there with
your dissonant opinions
you better not be the friggin you know
playing the
the the cheese grader with a stick
you can't have guy number 12 in the band
you know what i mean
you better you better not be the watch
more than like backup washboard player
you're going to get out there with your
freaking opinions especially
so you know it's just like at a company
right like imagine you had like
10 founders of a company and one guy's
out there so
i get why if they're like hey all we
have to do is
shut up it's like you're going to get
out there and like we're getting all
this heat and you're saying
saying all this stuff because you want
to you know be this guy that's part of
the culture war
and you're ruining our lives listen
that's what we were saying because he
posted andy knows
a book or whatever that's that was his
whole thing he said andy knows book was
good against
why antifa is bad but imagine like the
rest of them like behind closed doors
they're like yeah i mean we all love
andy know
like imagine the rest yeah but we
weren't stupid enough to tweet about it
yeah
yeah yeah if you go to their dressing
room it's just like all of them
photos of andy on the wall all the
inside of the two of us has got like
there's a shrine to him at the end of
the night
but they're just like we have to we
can't say this publicly
of course we all love andy no so that
was
i i don't know or or they all or they
were just like sick of this guy's [ __ ]
so it's hard to know
what the scenario is but i would say
that in
in my opinion in a band or a tv show or
a job or anything
it's like listen if you are not the
singer songwriter in a band
you won the lottery like you
legitimately
you were friends with a guy who got
really famous and now you're a
millionaire because of it
that's legitimately what happened so
right-wing or left-wing or opinions or
anything like that
like you do what he says like
that's in my opinion i i would kind of
uh
i've seen a lot of musicians that get
famous on both sides that
they start thinking they're you know
more important like this guy's like
you know i need to get out there with my
opinions it's like your opinions you're
like the
you know like the spoon player from
slipknot
number guy number 21 from slipknot yeah
yeah yeah yeah guy who plays the 19th
garbage lid
yeah yeah yeah it was interesting so i
had a look at this i look at this
article and he said um
this is talking about winston smith he
blamed a viral mob for his decision to
leave the band permanently
i failed to foresee that commenting on a
book critical of the far left could be
interpreted as approval of the equally
abhorrent far
right then he said winston said his
mumford and sonned
band mate had asked him to stay with
them after the tweet
but when he decided to step back from
the band another viral mob came after me
this time for the sin of apologizing
it's like once you've put yourself in
there you're gonna get wrecked no matter
where you are
he was he was literally doing the thing
where he's like oh
crap i'll apologize and everyone's like
yo why'd you apologize he's like okay
don't apologize there's only two buttons
i've only got two buttons
this guy doesn't have the temperament to
be you know and even if you read what he
says it's like
i agree kind of it's like you know he's
even what he just said now he's like
well i guess like me not being you know
left-wing makes me right-wing now and
you're like yeah you're right that's how
they see it
that is correct that's it it literally
says it here being labeled erroneously
just goes to show how
binary political discourse has become i
criticized the left so i must be the
right
or something like you don't you're not
aware of this
like this is uh like this is just news
to you now
like this guy's gonna be now now what he
goes on like
the dave reuben tour like saying [ __ ]
that we all like thought in 2013 i
apologize on the view
it goes and apologizes on the view or
you go
was the other song no man i i obviously
it sucks like
if you're you know whatever some guy in
some band and you're famous and you've
got all these opinions and you
post anything you think in your life's
over but
uh that is that is the situation so i i
i'm a big
and you know what i mean i shouldn't
trash him because he goes this is what i
want to do
and now i'm going to go say what i want
to do and he
made maybe he's pretty rich right now so
to be honest like
maybe there's nothing more to be said
than that's what this guy didn't you
know now he can
go start his one-man ukulele show that
won't be very
and you know he can write he can write
like you can do reaction videos didn't
you know
but
but this is the problem with like
uh the conservative people where they're
just like constantly flabbergasted with
journalists like they'll be like
these journalists are liars and you're
like yes that's the
that's the situation it's like okay now
now that we're on the same page on
planet earth
you understand that these people aren't
journalists and they lie
and if you're and if you're anyone smart
like if you run a company you understand
that like hey how can i use these
journalists
if i have something and by the way a lot
of these people are the same you go
if i if i want to use you like the dark
arts
for my company for my thing i need to
find a message that resonates with what
you're trying to say
and if you're like a big company right
now you go okay all these publications
want to say that you know
fat girls are hot so it's like i need to
make myself have fat girl stuff it's
like
if you're tucker carlson i need to you
know say some [ __ ] about cancer culture
if i want you to promote my
like so yes all of these journalists are
liars now
now okay now we're on the same page how
do you what are we doing
and i think that for me i mean try to i
try to make funny stuff right
you know it sounds like you try to have
interesting conversations and you try
whatever right but it is it's like
it is like i i've relatives that are
like this and it's like they get
fixated on like it'll be
the equivalent of like they're dating a
girl and they're like oh this girl just
is like this and you're like yes that's
how she is that's correct you know what
i mean
like they're not changing like no that's
what journalists are they're they're
all liars yes correct politicians are
liars
so what what now i uh does that make
sense
yeah absolutely mama i think it's the
mad thing is i can see it from both
sides because i can understand why
is a conservative you know a daily wired
guy a shapiro kind of guy tucker carlson
kind of guy you think well this is
unfair
the press continue to say things that we
know
are wrong logically they don't make
sense they're hypocritical they're in
inconsistent or whatever so you think
well okay
i understand that highlighting the
hypocrisy might be compelling to you
and it might actually garner views but
on the other side of the argument it
doesn't seem to be actually changing
anything it's not moving
anything at all so you just think well i
mean it makes for kind of like
fun woke bashing viewing
if you have that let that sort of
political leaning and you agree with
that
but it's not going to further your
agenda because you've done this
3 000 times before and it doesn't appear
to make any
any difference you're right this is the
this is the status quo this is how
everything works it's written into the
source code of the
operating system that you you and
everybody else is living in
but the problem is that because the left
dominates the media and they have
control of these narratives mostly
usually that you have a lot of sort of
reactionaries from the right that says
oh well we
this is terrible it's outrageous we
can't have this
yeah yeah no that exactly and it
and to me it's it's kind of i guess the
reason it
um i don't know like even right now like
as i'm saying i'm kind of like
like maybe going too hard on some of
these people if you want to say but it's
the same way when you go
remember when like there are valid like
criticisms of donald trump as a
president
but when everyone was out there being
insane being like he's worse than hitler
you kind of you know most normal people
i think when someone goes
i have a bunch of things about trump
yeah
yeah join the guy shut up shut up yeah
like you know what i mean
and it's the same thing with this where
it's like
it's like uh grifting almost you know
where they just like
take real issues and it and then uh
bastardize them into like partisan
things where it's like no this doesn't
have to be like a partisan
thing that like you know uh youtube
censorship and obviously it is probably
more conservatives more but it's like
it's everyone and it's like there are
certain issues where it's like that's
why it's hard to touch them because
like abortion is just a partisan issue
if you're this you're this if it's this
this there's no change in anyone's mind
and it's like they they try to use the
dark arts of like
galvanizing their base on these issues
and just
turn them into partisan issues when like
a lot of times they kind of didn't have
to be
and i think like comedy would be a
perfect example it's like dude edgy
comedy shouldn't be like a left-wing
right-wing thing
and i understand that it kind of is but
it won't that's going to swing back like
and so i don't really want to be part of
this like
movement to being like if you like edgy
comedy that's conservative and you're
like
no you you want it to be that because
you want to like attach yourself to this
like cultural power right now
for views so i guess i like resent like
uh like drifting by like machine
to like a gulp up uh
cultural movements and then uh try to
use them for like political reasons well
it's kind of like the boy that cried
wolf
in one way you know if if everybody's
racist then nobody is racist
if everything is racist then nothing is
racist and
you're right as well after a while the
donald trump stories you just thought
you can't one-up this anymore there's no
more
shy of getting into his sexual kinks
which will kind of
already got did you know there's almost
no way that you can take this to that
one ups the story so that people will
actually take notice
and when there's so much of a flood you
can't what are you gonna
what are you gonna do now what are you
gonna talk about now but there is
nowhere else for you to scale this up
and um you're right what happens is that
legitimate concerns get lost within a
a big avalanche of people jumping onto
something that they know is just going
to get agreement from their side and
generate clicks yeah i think so
where it's yeah that's where it becomes
that struggle like you said once you
i think a lot of people like you know
the jim jeffries even like yo he got
famous off this like gun control bit and
then it was like before he knew it he's
like this leveling pundit right like
before that he was like you know getting
drunk and having sex with girls like
you know kind of i don't know like
australian frat sort of
comedy or whatever you want to call it
right but which i like but
it just you know you have one one thing
and it becomes that and i kind of
so you do you have to you kind of fight
back against it and make
you know make other things and you uh
try to decide what you want to be
and i don't know there isn't like a
right answer i think that's like the
whole you know being an artist part but
if you're just trying to make as much
money as possible as quick as possible
or
grow as quick as possible i think you
just end up doing that right
did you see what the couple who
came out of their house with guns last
year
mccloskeys yeah haven't they released
like a brand of hot sauce or something
what have they done
they've done i swear that they've
merchandised themselves somehow what
have they done it's like i've seen
silhouettes of them posted on mugs or
something
dude that's so funny like having people
over and or going to someone's house and
bringing your leg on mccloskey's
one of the same things right you've got
someone that's kind of found some sort
of success
a little bit of clout online like okay
how long can we rinse this for
the silhouette of him and his wife stood
with an ar-15 outside of their house and
some hot sauce toilet roll we got
condoms
yeah trigger you know triggered hot
sauce or whatever right
but um there was yeah i'm not triggered
but uh have you ever read the book like
i mean a lot of this stuff
where i'm applying to politics and and
marketing and it's all
always like for one what's your goal but
you know like tipping point have you
ever read any of those kind of books
um i i i'm not sure if it's tipping
point
or one of the other ones it might have
been
another malcolm gladwell book but i
think i think it might be tipping point
but
he talks a lot about that with with uh
vans and airwalk um but
it's like there's two ways to go right
if
if your brand is like taking off really
quickly
you know option one is you pour as much
gasoline on it as possible
and try to like milk it as quick as
possible and that you know you kind of
need to decide whether you're that kind
of brand or whether you can actually
pivot those fans into something else or
and then there's option two where you
actually push back against it
which you know it's like you know again
if i do like a big video that was
popular with like conservatives then the
next week i tried to do something like
there was again like i did the next week
i came out where it was like it's not
always pc culture and then i kind of
when uh i felt like it was i you know i
was doing like
a lot of videos about like fox and cnn
being bad and then if i felt like i was
kind of
too biased towards one side i tried to
go the other way so i in a lot of ways i
tried to
one like that's a little like less clean
of a branding but you're just like
listen i'm not gonna
stray away from who i actually am which
is like that i
i'm not gonna say one side's good and
one side's bad like i'm
just everyone's people and i think that
i'm focused on that and then
and then if you start finding yourself
like growing too quick and it's
the wrong way you kind of you pour
what's the opposite of gasoline or yeah
yeah
sand yeah you pour some sand on sand on
it a little bit so i think that i
being naturally contrarian i maybe do it
too much but i think a lot of times i
pour
sand on my own like growth just out of a
spite for like not being you know it's
looked at a certain way
what are you being pulled through by
then is it just i want to find something
that's funny here
is it just i want to find the funniest
thing and try and go after that or is
there a
more sort of central thrust that you've
got
i think it's like how do you be the
greatest artist
like how can i be you know i i really do
love the idea of looking back at like a
body of work
and being like super proud of it you
know and not looking at him being like
all
and i've done you know i was in a pretty
successful band before comedy and then i
was in
uh you know i used to make tv and all
like traditional before i kind of moved
america
and i mean you know you ever like you
look at things and you go
ah that's when i got crappy and there is
this other element of like
listen if you can figure out how to make
money and you can figure out how to
uh you know monetize what you're doing
and then
be bigger like all that stuff's gonna
help like even just
the smallest things of you know having a
lot of success in new york
you can have you can kind of go do spots
at whatever clubs you want a little
easier right
so there's just you do need you can't
just be like in your basement so you do
need to
look at all of this stuff and be like no
i do need to grow and
so all right how much time should i put
in stand up is this is that lacking like
how much time
should i be doing the videos like and
then when you're doing the videos you go
am i kind of getting away from comedy am
i
getting preachy whatever it is right so
just like doing those analysis on
yourself but i think if you
say what the goal is is to when you're
when i'm you know
60 kind of look back and be like pretty
sick like stuff that i made you know
be like they'll have like eight stand
stand-up specials and you know like i'm
like all right you know six of those
were pretty freaking good
and just be like that you know that
movie i made like that was actually a
really good movie and
like that just looking back at stuff and
being like kind of which i have
a lot of things in my life that i look
back on artwise and i'm like pretty cool
you know you'll be like all right that
was good but then i have other things
where i look back and i go yeah we were
getting off track there that sucked it's
so funny man cause i wonder how many
people that have got success at the
moment
or uh was seeing sort of flying up
through the echelons of whatever it is
youtube podcasting
stand-up comedy acting movies whatever i
actually would look back
and say that they were proud of the body
of work that they're they're looking
behind or whether they look back and say
well that was just
it fed the algorithm it it sort of told
people what they wanted to hear it was a
bit hacky it was a bit melodrama but
whatever i i i'm on my yacht it doesn't
matter
i i definitely think that starting with
the end in mind of thinking yeah i want
a good body of work that i'm proud of
that other people think is cool
or other people think is interesting or
insightful or give them a
perspective that they don't see
elsewhere that
that by its nature will bring some
success with it
but as you said there you can be too
heterodox you can be the guy in the
basement
totally anti-marketing i don't need an
instagram i don't need a youtube channel
so well
you're gonna still be in your basement
like you need to play the game but know
that it's not about the game
that's a good way to put it i really
like that yeah you need to play the game
but it's
it's not the the game's there to help
you get what you want so you can you
know you can operate your business the
way that you want it to
yeah and and you make them and their
everything's little choices and that's
why i'm like a big proponent of like
instincts on stage
like when i'm on stage i'm not having a
dis conversation of should i
do this or should i do that it's like
i'm trusting you know the years of doing
it
and you so you when you do the opposite
of your instincts
as long as they're not you know getting
mal a lie mela-lined or whatever that
word would be
you kind of you're like a perfect
example on like a little scale
like if you look at everyone in the like
internet game for the most part
that does like videos like me they all
take their videos
and then they cut them with subtitles
and they usually put it in the box with
like the title over top of it right
right i mean
yeah they mean borrow it and
i i don't do that and i know that
it hurts my views especially on
platforms on phones
but it is this thing where going back to
like the body of work thing
you know things are going to change in
here and there but i'm like i do like
like looking at all the having all these
sketches that like look the way that
they're supposed to look and
maybe don't get shared as much right now
but i think if someone that like
cares about good things look through all
my stuff they kind of
will look at it like it was a a sketch
that was made like in that context and
not
you know this like internet thing or
something i don't know so
to me that's like a sacrifice i'm
willing to like make because of like how
i wanted to be seen or something
people really struggle to work out
what's a trend and what's like an
evergreen addition to the body of work
so there's
certain new things that get added on
that you're like wow this wasn't a thing
before it is a thing now
and it still will be in 20 years time
this is
a game-changing pivot or an extra little
limb that we've added on to
whatever the thing totally but sometimes
it's just a little wiggle in the market
or a little trend that comes through
and you're gonna look back i was
listening to tim dillon and he had one
of the dudes from
kerb on i can't remember the guy it
wasn't larry it was somebody else
and um he was talking about this guy you
talking this dude was so
out of touch with a lot of the the
trends and stuff that were going on at
the moment
but found tim's content
hilarious but it didn't have a [ __ ]
clue about
tick tock like didn't really understand
how podcasts worked
obviously not finger on the pulse but
[ __ ] epic comedian who really
understands his craft
jeff garland i can't remember even if
you said the guy's name i wouldn't
remember
um but but basically he was saying if
you think right okay so tim you've
managed to
like you're doing it now but you're
doing it
for eternity as well type thing you know
you're marrying the evergreen and the
current
and i think that that's like a real art
form
yeah and some of them you go you know
what i'm going to do this because it's
like a growth piece and i'm going to
then you know there's always that like
one for them one for me
came back in the day but then you're
like who's them you know um
but when the the yeah when they when
they when
it really started shifting and tick tock
has thrown a pretty big wrench into this
where it really is
like people make their videos um
i guess it would be 1280 1920 reverse
right so
people are making you know legitimate
content and i remember
i was doing you know i've made like
directed commercials and that sort of
stuff
right and when i was in uh canada i
remember doing like this big campaign
where it was starting
where we were shooting on a like an
alexa like you know on camera you make
movies on and shoot
huge commercials on and they would tape
off the sides of the lens
to to so we're
so you know so you know what frame but
you shoot 4k right and then we would it
would tape it off because you know that
you're going to be shooting like that
and it was just like man like this sucks
like
so there is this element of but that's
what it is our phones are that
and is that going to be the the majority
of how people
view videos for the rest of time i mean
you you there's a reason why
even just from like an ad sales
perspective
youtube's the only thing that like
really properly converts
you know except for you know to ticket
sales
to sponsorships like there's a reason
why
uh youtube views are worth
legitimately 20 times more money as a
tick-tock view because no one's going
from their phone
so there is something to be said about
like when
i kind of noticed that when i first
moved here i was like all of the big
comedians are like low-key youtube stars
like you don't think of that but they
are
whether that's their podcast on youtube
or you know even rogan it's like he's a
youtube star like that's what's going to
drive those
salesmen that's what drives it so
that and there might be something to be
said about the fact that yeah because
they're watching stuff like how it's
supposed to be watched so they're like
actually connecting with it where the
other way
it's it's not really designed for you to
actually fall in love with it it's just
designed for you to
not leave maybe i don't know and dude
i think that's totally totally correct
like think about
you can do a thing that at the time you
kind of wanted to do or you were
tricked into doing but in retrospect you
wish that you hadn't done like we've all
done that with
a party or a nightmare or
and i think that tick tock kind of
really is
the most aggressive in terms of how that
works
and because you're just flicking through
this content so quickly
your ability to actually create a a
relationship with the creator
it almost doesn't exist think about how
much
time people spend listening to your boys
cast podcast or modern wisdom or
[ __ ] like the joe rogan experience
you're talking of
like hundreds of hours they spend the
same listening to all three of those
podcasts
yeah yeah yeah uh but you think like
you're like a [ __ ]
it's like you're a a god in their ears
you know there's nothing else
you've got the airpods and you're
walking around it's just your sound
yeah and you've got this real long time
and attention to build a connection and
then
you need just a little thing to convert
them but there's no way like
the equivalent number of followers that
you would need on tick tock to be able
to convert like no one's clicking off
tick tock to go buy ryan
tickets i know people with three million
four million followers on tick tock that
can't sell out like they can't headline
a comedy club
like they can't sell the tickets like
that you know and i have you know i
remember
i have the only thing you can do with
tick tock is if you
really do it right you can get them to
youtube yeah that's it it's a front end
of the funnel to get them to a real
platform
yeah i've been saying that anyways the
algorithm works and you can get in front
of people so it is a
you know people pay a lot of money to
get their things in front of people and
that algorithm can
put you in front of but the only thing i
mean if you're
proper like what i am i think you gotta
the only thing you can do is get them to
youtube from that desperately
what's the what's the hardest thing that
you do as part of your process at the
moment is it
writing is it scripting is it editing is
it actually shooting the stuff what is
it
artistic yeah yeah but like sometimes
i'll be like when i'm writing i'm like
oh writing's like the hardest part and
then when i'm filming i'm just like okay
let's just get the filming over and then
when i'm editing it's like [ __ ]
editing sucks and my chicks like
yo maybe you just don't like filmmaking
it just depends you know what the the
truth is
um that i this is the thing that i've
realized
about myself over the years and i don't
always get it right
but i like all of them as long as i get
to do just that
i hate the one i hate when i'm squeezing
anything in
and that's like the worst part so if i'm
writing like i really need to block off
where it's like no
i'm writing today or the very least like
till three today like the first half of
my days writing the second half of my
days this
it's when i try to do all of the things
and i hate all of them
so when i'm really trying to work on
stand-up and then it's like i have to go
edit this video
i hate it but when i say you know what i
just filmed five videos
and for the next you know four days i'm
editing i don't hate editing anymore
or when i say that uh like i'm taking
this week i'm gonna write six scripts i
don't hate writing anymore
so i don't mind anything when i can be
when i can really like get into it
and then at that point i like i don't
mind all of it but
probably the the one that's the hardest
out of anything
and this just isn't me this is the
probably i think with just an objective
truth
uh writing stand up is the hardest thing
out of all the things
why because everything else
that you're doing is like most of those
games are about being consistently
really good
and that's a little easier to to be
than whereas stand-ups about like the
one magical home run
so it's like you're you're you're
writing all week really what you're
looking for is that
one thing which was like duh that like
whatever
three ideas came together to form like
the perfect idea with the perfect thing
you're looking for like home run like
you know nuggets of gold i think jerry
seinfeld said and that's really where
you are you're mining for like these
real
real gold nuggets like you get these
these one lines where you're like that
is the perfect
freaking line that's so funny whereas
the other stuff it's like
uh you're you're like you write a sketch
and it's like you really wrote like 20
funny jokes and
none of them like most of those jokes if
you wrote stand up like none of them
would make it
you know you're doing more than one
speaker and like that wasn't good enough
so it's a
stand-up's harder because you're you
really got to be on your game if you're
looking for like home runs and it's
and a lot of times it's the least
rewarding because you spend you know two
three hours doing stand up and you go
try it that night and you kind of had
nothing and
so it it's in a lot of ways you just
like if i did a video i
would have made one and it would have
been good in this same time so that's
why
i think stand-ups uh tougher than other
art forms it's a really good insight in
productivity as well that like my
favorite day is a wednesday
so on wednesdays all i do is just go
back through the episodes that are
coming up
for the next week and i know that i
don't have anything else no emails
there's nothing
start the day go at the gym or whatever
and that's it i have one i have multiple
things but they're all the same thing
same as editing for videos or whatever
and it's like and even emails like if
you've got emails doing
oh well i've got like i can sit down i
can put the tv on i can watch some
some sport or chill out or do whatever
and i've got a couple of hours of emails
to do you actually don't hate the emails
that much you're totally right it's when
they intrude
when you've got just little fragments
snippets of things because you never get
anything done and then you resent
yourself for not having got anything
done and then you think god
what am i the sort of person that can't
even answer a [ __ ] email while he's
supposed to be editing this thing
so exactly yep you have to be a you have
to be a douchebag so it's like you have
to
you have to set those like limits it's
kind of like
with anyone you when you have to be like
i do this this night to some degree
you know or or like let people in your
life know
that you know hey like your agent's
manager is anyone important or whatever
you go
hey i like i check my emails before it's
12 so if you
it's after like you know call me just
because i really like you
and then you have to deal with a little
bit of them being like oh like you know
yeah oh mr big shot like god like
don't email me like you and you just
that's just what
but if you have to you have to honestly
get better at like selling your
system to people in a way that just
doesn't make you seem like too much of a
[ __ ] loser because it is
it is like corny to have to be that guy
that's like
hey like you know i i don't like answer
the phone or emails
after five o'clock and that's you have a
little window like it makes you feel
like a psychopath or
or i do interviews this day and it's you
know you guys
just gotta figure out how to be able to
like sell that in a cool way and
sometimes it is just being like
no i know this is like lame but like
because of the way my writing thing goes
i gotta turn my phone off
so i have to be like you know you can
kind of say it like that
too right the choices between having the
the silly rules
and people calling you an autist or
not getting work done it's like look
like we're all the only reason anybody
here is getting [ __ ] paid is because
i get the work done
so we need to make that this is the
priority and everything else
comes after man ryan long ladies and
gentlemen people want to check out your
stuff where should they go
uh the boys cast with ryan long is my
podcast every week first podcast
exclusively for the boys
and uh at youtube.com
ryan long comedy and everywhere else on
ryan long comedy i release a sketch
every single monday and then the podcast
every friday and then the boys cast with
on patreon as well uh episode comes out
every
friday also at patreon.com
basement beautiful love it man thank you
so much for coming on
yeah great dude that was a great
conversation thanks for having me man
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace